[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i uh been keep an eye out on the
insiders doing all the heavy lifting
here i just like to sit back and
occasionally i'll be stealth and maybe
get a story for you and i'm always
curious what tom pelicero the nfl
network is doing you can follow him tom
pelosiero on twitter at tom pelosiero
last two weeks now that's been march
madness tom with everything that's
happened the last 11 days i ran down the
list of
russ was a seahawk brady retired wentz
occult adam's a packer ridley wasn't
suspended mack was a bear von miller
free agent trubisky with the bills
desean watson prepping for the grand
jury and troy aikman and joe buck worked
for fox
that's the last 11 days
i was on the phone around midnight last
night with a gm and we were talking
about this same thing and i go do you
realize russell wilson got traded nine
days ago it's not even in the top 10
right now in terms of like the big
stories not by importance but just by
the number of things that are you know
close to that big
it's been a year unlike any other in the
nfl i think that we always
look at all these situations when you're
kind of trying to game this out before
you head into the off season of okay
this could happen that would trigger
this most of the time that stuff doesn't
happen
this year it actually is happening and i
think that that's also a function of the
direction that the nfl is going when you
come out of an offseason a year ago
where you had a matthew stafford who
said i want to move on the line said
okay we'll accommodate you have a
blockbuster trade uh going to the rams
you had aaron rodgers who made his
feelings known and generated real change
that led to different roster moves and
then a new contract
in this offseason players are figuring
out the top players not the the rank and
file but the top players are figuring
out much like the nba they have a great
deal of power over
uh where they end up and right now
you're seeing a variety of players
exercising that various forms
devontae adams out of all of the things
we talk about the biggest surprise is
devonte adams leaving green bay
why
i'm not gonna say why didn't we see this
happening but it felt like everything
was falling into place roger's coming
back therefore he wants devontae adams
next thing i know devonte adams wants to
tell me about growing up a raider fan
and wants to play with his former
college teammate and i guess they live
next door to one another like how did we
not see this coming
this really traces back to
last summer when the packers were trying
to do a long-term extension with devante
adams and one of the issues in the wide
receiver market has been the fact that
julio jones on the extension that he
signed in atlanta i want to see it was
before the 2019 season at 22 million
dollars per year has been the highest
paid receiver on a traditional extension
for several years now but you also have
deandre hopkins who when he got traded
from the texans to the cardinals signed
a two-year extension on top of the three
years he had left on his old deal at
27.25 million dollars per year now every
team and most agents will look at that
and say that's not a true 27.25 because
the cardinals didn't pay any of the
money on the old contract they basically
did a new five-year deal that was in
line with the julio jones deal but
devonte adams and his agents were
pressing to go beyond deandre hopkins
the packers were willing to go beyond
julio jones make him the highest paid
receiver by their metrics that led to a
huge gap in the negotiations and so this
was festering throughout the course of
the season devonte adams said many times
number one he would not take a cut he
would not take a hometown discount to
stay in green bay and number two he
didn't want to be franchise tagged it
would have been malpractice for the
packers not to tag him but when they
tried to jump start negotiations and
they were as my colleague ian rapport
reported
late last night from adam's agents the
packers were ultimately
willing to go above and beyond what the
raiders did in terms of money at that
point though adams had already said i'm
not playing on the tag i want to go to
las vegas it put the packers in a
position where it behoove the
organization to explore the alternative
the other remarkable thing with this
stand was on wednesday
my understanding from both sides was
this trade was dead the raiders had
backed away from it they actually i was
told had called other teams about
potential other wide receiver deals they
weren't able to get something done they
came back to it on thursday they upped
their offer to the one and the two this
year things accelerated quickly they had
that monster new contract that does go
beyond deandre hopkins in place and now
davonte adams is a very rich man and
aaron rodgers is a man wondering who
he's gonna be throwing to in 2022. okay
if aaron rodgers had known this
would he have resigned with green bay
aaron rodgers knew about the frustration
for devonte adams and the packers had
looped aaron rodgers in
on the trade conversations not putting
them on the phone with the raiders of
course but i mean they had talked with
him coach matt lafleur had spoken with
him rogers
more than anyone understands what it's
like to be frustrated with the packers
and frustrated about why they wouldn't
step up sooner with the contracts that's
literally what played out last
off-season with him and triggered that
entire chain of events so really from
this point forward it's about what can
they do and i would tell you this dan
the packers are going to be aggressive
they're going to be looking in the trade
market they're going to be looking in
what remains of the free agent market i
anticipate that their wide receiver
depth chart is going to look uh vastly
different in the days and weeks to come
than it does right now well i'm
wondering about this you got uh julio
jones
jarvis landry juju smith schuster odell
beckham might be out there am i missing
anybody
those are some of them odell you
remember he tore his acl retort in
mid-february so if you're talking a
normal
eight to nine month recovery he's not
playing before middle of next season and
so that's gonna affect obviously the
money he gets it's gonna affect the rams
which is part of why they went out and
got uh alan robinson uh robert woods
right now is available he's also coming
off an acl so that's a guy that matt
lafleur overlapped with uh with the rams
he potentially could be a trade target
for green bay the other guys i mean
julio was saying out there juju is
sitting out there marquez valdez
scantling who's was with the packers and
has not yet signed uh it's still on the
free agent market and then some of those
you know those veterans like the jarvis
landry's who have been released as well
as julio all those are potential options
here you know that rogers wants to have
guys who have done it not to say that he
won't work with a rookie but if you look
at the history of rookie receivers with
aaron rodgers usually their production
has an uptick two three years in well
rogers isn't worried about 2024 at this
point it's about how are we gonna do
this in 2022 so they'll go out i would
anticipate they'll acquire one if not
two veterans uh and that may happen
sooner than later tom pelosero nfl
network reporter where do we stand with
duchaun watson
deshaun watson eliminated the browns on
thursday morning and caused an entire
storm uh with that announcement that we
can discuss as well last night he
eliminated the carolina panthers and so
at this point
watson's choices are down to the falcons
and the saints the saints were really
the front runner from go they have the
most you know win ready team outside of
arguably cleveland of course but watson
didn't want to go to a cold weather
place in the northern united states um
you know but you've got a saints team
that's got alvin kamara they've got
michael thomas it sounds like watson's
been in communication with both those
guys on practically a daily basis
they've got talent on that roster and
then you got the falcons who are kind of
still in this transition phase i mean
dan i'm standing here talking to you
right now and i'm not sure i can name
three receivers on the falcon's current
roster all right they got kyle pitts
yeah i do know that uh ola maybe
zacchaeus i believe was back on an rfa
tender uh yep i'm sure somebody else out
there is thinking why don't you think of
this guy i can't even name him off the
top of my head so the thing is when you
have this type of a trade and we're
talking about unprecedented compensation
in terms of three first-round picks
additional picks and likely a player
involved as well
you run into this issue of okay we're
getting the quarterback but now we have
vastly fewer resources to go out and put
pieces around them so if you're joining
a team like the falcons that's in this
transition phase even though they do
have really good players like aj terrell
on defense
kyle pitts on offense you have to wonder
about that and so that's definitely part
of watson's decision making right now
because he's got personal ties to
atlanta he knows arthur blank former
falcons ball boy uh he'd love just from
a personal level to go back there but
you have to weigh that out i mean john
watson has lived the life of a guy who
threw for what was it 4 500 yards and
went 4 and 12 on a terrible team
he doesn't want to be a part of that
again so
that's part of what he's evaluating here
we thought the decision was going to
come yesterday that was the plan uh by
late last night it became apparent that
wasn't going to happen because most of
the owners he'd be calling were in bed
so the hope is that he's going to make a
decision today because there's so much
business around the nfl that is held up
right now between matt ryan's future
baker mayfield's future
there are free agent quarterbacks like
jameis winston and marcus mariota who
are waiting to see how this plays out as
well there are other free agents at
different positions wondering where this
is going to go i mean there's a lot of
dominoes that this watson decision is
going to knock over yeah and jimmy
garoppolo as well baker mayfield how
much leverage does he have to truly get
out of cleveland
leverage is a fair question dan because
he's under contract for i believe it's
about 18.8 million on the fifth year
option this year like any quarterback if
you decide to carry it out into the off
season you're talking about not having
the stored in quarterback there through
otas which are all voluntary not there
in the off season program if you skip
mini camp it's a relatively moderate
fine of a little over a hundred thousand
dollars if you miss all three days now
you're into training camp and you have
that cloud that hovers over the
organization do the browns want to be a
part of that or do they want to move on
you know what i was told yesterday was
when desean watson informed the browns
that they were out on him the browns
were reaching out to baker mayfield and
they had talked with them they'd let his
representation know at the combine that
they were going to be examining options
but for baker mayfield and knowing his
makeup this is just not a situation he
wanted to be a part of so what i was
told was they reached out to him and
said hey we'll come down to austin we'll
meet with you we'll talk it out we want
to find the path forward you're our guy
baker mayfield's response was
no
just don't worry about it he feels like
this bridge has been burned the time to
move on is right now the browns told his
agent they're not going to accommodate
the trade request but it increasingly
appears that these two sides are headed
for a divorce and again the deshaun
watson decision and all the other things
that will happen after that will dictate
what the potential spots are yeah but
what kind of trade market is there for
baker mayfield like he's coming off an
injury pl injury season uh injured
season and didn't play well
uh
so i
see this is where i i was surprised that
they put out that letter saying goodbye
to cleveland because if you're baker
mayfield knowing his makeup but being a
competitor it's like hey you want to
flirt with him i'm still the quarterback
here i would i would play this out in
cleveland and if i played well
now i have leverage now
you want to trade me i can go to
someplace else and more people would be
interested or the browns would have to
step up and and extend him but i don't
know if like i don't want to give up
much for baker mayfield right now
there's not a lot of precedent it's
happened in the lead but there's not a
ton of precedent for a number one
overall pick but really any first round
quarterback to play out the fifth year
option so already baker mayfield was in
this weird lame duck territory where yes
the message would be hey come in ball
out for 18.8 million if you do that
you're going to be getting paid 40
million dollars plus a long-term
extension if you don't then obviously
you know all parties are going to move
on so you can get on board with that at
some level but then when you have this
very public flirtation with desean
watson it does change just the dynamics
a little bit i mean baker is a big
personality right he's going to lead a
certain way in the locker room and you
know perhaps on some level when it feels
like that's being undercut his ability
to lead that way um that has an effect
on the situation he's just the feeling
is from what i was told he feels like
that bridge has been burned he wants to
move on you know what the trade market
would be again 18.8 million is not an
astronomical number for another team to
take on and baker you know 14 months ago
he was leading the browns to their first
playoff win in like 26 years they went
11-5 i think they scored 40 points in
that game it's not like he's been a
bottom five quarterback within the nfl
at his best uh he's been certainly a
sufficient starter for a team and so
there's a handful of teams have
unsettled quarterback situations right
now you've got teams like the seahawks
where remember gm john schneider is
close with john dorsey who drafted him
number one overall scott mcloone is
close with schneider was advising dorsey
at the time you can envision a scenario
where hey bring in baker have him
compete with drew locke there's all
kinds of different things dan that could
end up happening here uh but you're
running out of chairs i mean this really
is a game of musical chairs there's only
so many places that guys can go which is
why
you know mitch trubisky jumps quickly on
the steelers offer for the chance to
compete um there's not a lot of places
that baker or any quarterback at this
point can be the walk in the door
starter outside of indianapolis which i
imagine is going to know pretty quickly
after the watson decision what direction
they're going to go as well yeah but if
chris mortenson's source is correct that
the browns wanted an adult at
quarterback and they were reaching out
to deshaun watson like how clueless can
you be that you want an adult and your
adult is desean watson
i can't speak to mort's reporting on
that particular subject i certainly
understand why there would be certain
frustrations uh from the browns
organization about what happened in 2021
i mean you finally get a playoff win you
seem to have momentum you got a really
good young roster and you just struggle
throughout the course of the season but
part of it was
you mentioned it dad he played hurt and
this is one of the things that i think
and this is not a defensive baker
mayfield it's more of a a broader point
everybody always wants to say you know
the guys that play hurt oh they're so
tough and it's so respectable and well
he's doing it for his team that was a
mistake
when you play badly and you're hurt
nobody's just like well he's playing
badly because he's hurt but man good
efforts no baker sucks now it's like i
was at the game uh i think it was
against arizona where he popped the
shoulder out for the second time i mean
i thought the guy had like broken his
arm i mean it was he went down he's
riding on the ground in pain i mean he
was playing through a lot he was playing
in the harness the shoulders popping in
and out he had like a calf or some other
issue that actually was the worst injury
throughout the course of season that's
the one that wasn't getting better i
mean he played through a lot again i'm
not defending baker mayfield i'm just
saying anytime you got a guy who's
playing through a bunch of different
injuries you have to just like jimmy
garoppolo last year where he hurts the
finger and then he throws a terrible
interception in tennessee it's like yeah
quarterbacks are hurt you're not gonna
play as well it's you know you always
have to take that into the evaluation
it's really about do you feel like a
baker mayfield can be the right leader
for your team do you feel like you can
capture what he was in 2020 everybody
was praising kevin stefanski he was the
coach of the year that year in part for
getting mayfield playing at that high of
a level uh we've seen that it's in there
for mayfield he's just got to do it
consistently
thank you tom uh we appreciate your time
great job this week
you got it dan thank you that's tom
pelicero nfl network reporter